moving on now to the war in Ukraine a
small group of United Nations experts
remains at Europe's largest nuclear
plant for a second day checking on
possible damage there a convoy of
inspectors arrived at the Russian
control facility near the front lines
yesterday but it's unclear how much
access they had to critical areas
Deborah Potter has more from Keys
massive explosions near the zaparisia
plant yesterday threatened to derail the
nuclear inspector's Mission but iaea
director Rafael Grossi and his team
braid the shelling and finally managed
to inspect the damage at the Russian
occupied nuclear power plant following
six months of War I will continue to be
worried about the plant until we have a
situation which is more stable which is
more predictable the plant needs a
constant supply of electricity to cool
down spent nuclear fuel as a result of
fighting actors that zapparesia have had
to use backup generators on several
occasions explains nuclear expert Hamish
to Britain Gordon well when it goes on
to backup power we're in a sort of Lance
Chance Saloon as it were there is
nothing after that you know if this is a
nuclear power station in the U.S or the
UK you know maybe once in a generation
this is the second time in a week if the
backup goes a chain reaction is set in
motion if that is not called on a
regular basis uh it then creates what we
call a meltdown
potentially a nuclear catastrophe that's
why Grassi has left a team of at least
five inspectors at the plant who will
continue to work there until the weekend
with one goal to prevent a global
disaster
he says his organization won't be
leaving the plant as they intend
establishing a constant presence there
and today a Russian Ambassador in Vienna
said they were happy with two inspectors
to remain there on a permanent basis
scale
Deborah patta in Ukraine we thank you